hi everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation and
today i think it's going to be a quick
episode sometimes i think it's going to
be quick and then you know i keep on
going
forever but this one all i want to do
is say a few remarks about
schrodinger's equation and
then after those insights which i hope
that you'll
find interesting i'll then move on to
the generalized
version of schrodinger's equation
because so far
in this series all i did was
the schrodinger equation for a single
particle moving in one spatial dimension
so i just want to generalize that
to the situation of many particles
moving
say through three spatial dimensions you
know a more ordinary realistic
situation okay so
first for the few brief remarks on
schrodinger's equation itself let me
write that equation out so that we all
recall
where we are good all right so remember
what schrodinger's equation was it said
i h bar d psi
say if x and t dt
equals minus h bar squared over
2m d2 psi of x
t d x squared
and there are a number of things i could
say about
this equation but let me just first
note the following it is
perhaps a little bit strange that
there is an i in this equation right
you're familiar from
your studies in high school that i as
the square root of
negative 1 is a useful
idea a useful concept to introduce
mathematically
but you know there's no
device that measures how
much in an imaginary sense a quantity
may be
like devices measure real numbers so
at first blush you might be a little bit
surprised to see a number like i
cropping into a physical equation
now first off bear in mind that when it
comes to interpreting
what psy is telling us physically
remember
what we do we talk about probability of
x and t
and we immediately look at the norm
squared which gets rid of any
imaginary quantities because this guy
over here
this is a real number and it's also a
non-negative
real number and if properly normalized
it can play the role of a probability
and that's
what born max born told us that we
should think about this
as a probability of finding the particle
at say given
position at a given moment in time
but i'd like you to recall in our
derivation
of schrodinger's equation where the eye
actually
came in in a more mechanical sense and
you'll recall
it came in because i took this on
this starting point for what a
probability wave
might look like as e to the i k x
minus omega t and you know there's your
i
right there now remember this is cosine
of
kx minus omega t plus
i sine of kx minus omega t
and when i introduced this particular
form
i said hey this is merely
a convenient device for being able to
talk about
cosine and sine
simultaneously not sort of having to go
through a calculation multiple times for
each of those
possible wave shapes but i actually
slipped in
something more than that in the
derivation because you recall
that when i looked at say d psi
dt right and of course we look at this
expression over here and we can just get
that to be minus
i omega e to the i kx
minus omega t namely minus i
omega psi of x and t
the fact that the result
after taking a single derivative
is proportional to psi itself that
would not have turned out to be the case
if we were dealing with
cosines and sine separately because the
derivative of
cosine gives you something sine division
gives you
cosine they flip around and it's only
in this combination that
the result of a single derivative is
actually proportional to
that combination and the proportionality
is with
a factor of i and so
that's the vital part in the derivation
where we have to look at this
combination
cosine plus i sine because if this
fellow is not proportional
to psi itself then our derivation it's a
too strong a word our
our motivation for the form of the
schrodinger equation would have fallen
through
we wouldn't have been able to then
equate this to
something involving d2 psi dx squared
again
which is proportional to psi itself if
these weren't both proportional to psi
we wouldn't have an equation to speak of
and the only way that that worked out is
by looking at
this particular combination of cosines
and sines what a messy page but i hope
you
get the basic idea so fundamentally from
the get-go schrodinger's equation has to
involve
imaginary numbers again this particular
probability interpretation
means that we don't have to think about
those imaginary numbers as something we
literally go out and measure
but they are a vital part of the way
that the wave
unfolds through time okay that was point
number one what is point number two
point number two is that this equation
this schrodinger's equation
is a linear equation in the sense
that you don't have any psi squares or
psi cubes in there
and that's very nice because if i was to
take
one solution to that equation called psi
1
and multiply it by some number and take
another solution called psi 2. whoops i
did not mean to do that
and come on stop doing that
psi 2 then this would also
solve the schrodinger equation this
combination
because this is a linear equation i can
look at any linear combination
of solutions and it too will be a
solution that's very
very vital that's like a key part of
quantum mechanics
it goes by the name of superposition
that you can take
distinct solutions of the equation add
them together and still have
a solution that needs to be physically
interpreted we'll
come back to the the curious
features of physics that that yields but
the reason i'm bringing it up here is
you'll note that i began with one very
particular form
for the wave function involving cosines
and sines in this combination
but the fact that i can add multiple
versions of that onsite say with
different values of k and omega standing
in the right relationship so that they
solve the shortage of equation
means that i can have a wave function
psi of x and t
which is equal to a sum or in general an
integral
of the solutions that we studied before
some of solutions of the
canonical sort that we began with
so we're not limited as my point to
having solutions that literally look
like that we can take
linear combinations of them and get wave
shapes of a whole variety of
much more interested much more varied
wave
shapes okay good those are the i think
those are the two
main points that i wanted to quickly go
over now
for the generalization of the
schrodinger equation
to multiple spatial dimensions and
multiple particles and that's that's
really quite
straightforward so we have i h bar
d psi dt equals minus h bar squared
over 2m psi of x and t and
you know i was doing it for the free
particle case but now i'm going to put
in the potential
that we also discussed in our derivation
so that's for one particle in one
dimension what would it be for
one particle say in three dimensions
well
you don't have to think hard to guess
what the generalization
would be so it's i h bar the psi
now instead of having x alone we have x1
x2 x3 and t i won't write down the
argument every time but i will
on occasion when it's useful what would
this be equal to well now we'll have
minus oh i left out the d2 dx squared
here
minus h bar squared over 2m
dx 1 squared
psi plus
d2 psi dx2
squared plus d2 psi
dx3 squared we just put all
of the derivatives all the second order
derivatives with respect to each
of the spatial coordinates and then plus
v of x1 x2 x3
times psi and i won't bother writing
down the argument so you see that the
only change is
to go from d2 dx squared that we had in
the
one-dimensional version to now
including the derivatives
in all of the three spatial directions
good not not too complicated on that
but now let's go to the case where say
we have two particles not one particle
two particles
well now we need coordinates for
each of the particles spatial
coordinates like the time coordinate
will be the same for them there's only
one dimension of time but each of these
particles
has their own location in space
that we need to be able to ascribe
probabilities for the particles being at
those locations so let's do that
so let's say that for particle 1 we use
say
x1 x2 and x3
for particle 2 let's say we use x4
x5 and x6
now what will the equation be well it
gets a little bit messy to write down
but you can guess it i'll try to write
small so
i h bar d psi
and now i have to put x 1 x 2
x 3 x 4 x 5
and x 6 and t
this guy derivative with respect to t
what is that equal to
well let's say particle number one has
mass m1 and particle
number two has mass m2 then what we do
is minus
h bar squared over 2m1 for the first
particle
now we look at d2 psi dx1 squared plus
d2 psi dx2 squared plus
d2 psi dx3 squared that's for
the first particle for the second
particle we now have to just add in
minus h bar squared over 2m2
times d2 psi
dx4 squared plus d2
psi dx5 squared plus
d2 psi dx6 squared
okay and in principle there's some
potential that will depend
on where the particles both
are located it can depend mutually on
their
positions so that means i'd add in v of
x1
x2 x3 x4
x5 x6 times
psi and that's the equation
that we are led to and
there's an important point here which is
that
especially because this potential
can depend generally on all
six of the coordinates three coordinates
for the first particle and three
for the second it's not the case that we
can write
psi for this whole shebang x1 through
x6 and t it's not that we can
necessarily split this
up say into phi of x1 x2
and x3 times say chi of
x4 x5 x6
sometimes we can pull things apart like
that but in general especially if you
have a general
function for the potential you can't so
this guy over here
this wave function the probability wave
it actually depends on all of the
six coordinates and how do you interpret
it so
if you want the probability that say
particle 1
is located at position x1 x2
x3 i'll put a little semicolon to pull
it apart and that particle 2
is at location x4 x5 x6 for some
specific numerical values of those six
numbers of the six coordinates
you'd simply take the wave function and
this is at say some particular time
you take the wave function at those
positions it won't bother
bother writing it down again and you
would
square that guy and if i was being
careful i wouldn't say directly at those
locations there should be an interval
around those locations blah blah but i'm
not going to worry about
those sort of details here because my
main point is
that this guy over here
depends upon in this case six spatial
coordinates now often times
people think about a probability wave as
living in our three-dimensional
world and the size of the wave at a
given location in our three-dimensional
world determines
the quantum mechanical probabilities but
that
picture is only true for a single
particle
living in three dimensions here we have
two particles
and this guy doesn't live in three
dimensions of space
this guy lives in six dimensions of
space and that's just for
two particles imagine that i had n
particles
in say three dimensions then the wave
function that i would write down would
depend on
x1 x2 x3 for the first particle
x4 x5 x6 for the second particle
and on down the line until if we had n
particles we would have three n
coordinates
as the last fella down
the line and we can include the t as
well so this
is a wave function over here
that lives in three n spatial
dimensions so let's say
n is a hundred or something a hundred
particle this is
a wave function lives in 300 dimensions
or if you're talking about the number of
particles say making up a human brain
whatever that is 10 to the
26 particles right this would be
a wave function that lives in three
times
10 to the 26th dimension so your
mental image of where the wave function
lives can be radically misleading if you
only think about the case of a single
particle in three dimensions where you
can literally think about
that wave if you want is sort of filling
our three dimensional environment you
can't see it
you can't touch that wave but you can at
least imagine it living in
our realm now big question is
is the wave function real is it
something out there physically is it
simply a mathematical device
these are deep questions that people
argue about but at least
in the single particle three-dimensional
case you can picture it if you want as
living in
our three-dimensional spatial expanse
but for
any other situation with multiple
particles
if you want to ascribe a reality to that
wave
you have to ascribe a reality to a very
high dimensional space
because that's the space that can
contain
that particular probability wave by
virtue
of the nature of the schrodinger
equation and how these wave functions
look so that's really the point that i
wanted to make again it took me a little
bit longer
than i wanted to i thought this would be
a real quickie but it's been a medium
duration one i hope you don't mind but
that's the lesson
the equation that summarizes the
generalization
of the single particle schrodinger
equation necessarily yields
probability ways wave functions that
live in high dimensional spaces
and so if you really want to think about
these probability waves as being real
you're led to think about the reality of
these higher dimensional spaces huge
number of dimensions
i'm not talking about string theory here
with like 10 11
26 dimensions i'm talking about enormous
numbers of dimensions
do people really think that way some do
some however think that
the wave function is merely a
description
of the world as opposed to something
that lives
in the world and that distinction allows
one to sidestep the question of whether
these high dimensional spaces are
actually
out there anyway so that's what i wanted
to
talk about today and that is your daily
equation looking forward to seeing you
next time until then
take care